puntualmente Cuál es la acusación contra
García Luna qué es lo que permitía el
entonces alto funcionario y quien
denunció que recibía recibía sobornos
bueno la actuación plantea que
estuvo durante muchos años trabajando al
mismo tiempo para el gobierno de México
un altísimo funcionario como el civil de
más alto Rango encargados de temas de
seguridad y con el el cartel de Sinaloa
específicamente ayudando principalmente
a Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán y a la vez el
recibía información y recibía dinero de
Estados Unidos a través de los programas
de ayuda bilateral para combatir
justamente que las drogas llegaran a
Estados Unidos es decir se le acusa de
ser una especie de triple agentes una
investigación que comenzó en Estados
Unidos se votó ante un gran Jurado en
Estados Unidos y actualmente
esperando el juicio este juicio que
comienza justamente mañana aquí en Nueva
York y es hasta ahora el juicio más
importante que ha derivado de el juicio
contra Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán El Líder
del Cartel De Sinaloa que ocurrió
también en Nueva York entre 2018 y
principios de 2019 Bueno usted ya lo
estaba mencionando García Luna trabajaba
para algo en el gobierno mexicano y
tenía vínculos con la DEA pero al mismo
tiempo con el cartel de Sinaloa cómo
pudo ocurrir esto durante tanto tiempo
bueno ocurrió durante más de una década
y parte de eso es de lo que queremos
descubrir en el en el juicio a ver
básicamente lo que el juicio va a
permitir es también hacernos una
pregunta muy importante acerca de cómo
Estados Unidos Elige a sus aliados en la
región en América Latina no es la
primera vez que una persona en quien el
gobierno de Estados Unidos ha confiado
termina siendo cuestionado o investigado
por corrupción Y también vamos a poder
conocer más acerca de cómo existían
estas colaboraciones y un poco Por qué
hay un fracaso que se ve en los números
de la guerra contra el narcos y la misma
persona que estaba encargada de evitar
que las drogas llegaran a Estados Unidos
era si según esta acusación la misma
persona que al mismo tiempo estaba
ayudando al cartel de Sinaloa bueno
Felipe Calderón fue presidente entre dos
mil seis y 2012 la captura de García
Luna se produce en 2019 porque tardó
tanto tiempo Bueno eso es otra pregunta
importante no solamente que los años
sino que además García Luna después de
dejar su puesto en México en 2012 se
mudó a Miami él vivió en Miami en una
una casa de más de tres millones de
dólares y y parte de todo eso es lo que
explicamos en un podcast que acabamos de
hacer acá acá en Nueva York que se llama
versus García Luna que es justamente
desgranando este juicio pero básicamente
se le investigó durante mucho tiempo
pero durante mucho tiempo no se hizo
nada Ahora vamos a aprender en el juicio
exactamente en qué ya su colaboración y
esperemos también entender Por qué no se
le juzgó desde antes